resuelve para eso la siguiente ecuación
es cuadrada menos 2 s
35 y 0 y bueno hay varios métodos para
resolver este tipo de ecuaciones las
famosas ecuaciones de segundo grado y
este tipo de ecuaciones que vamos a
encontrar en muchas partes de las
matemáticas que vayas a ver a lo largo
de tu vida y en general se utiliza el
método de la fórmula general de
ecuaciones de segundo grado sin embargo
quiero ver otra forma de solucionar este
tipo de ecuaciones y en esta ocasión lo
que quiero hacer es factorizar el
polinomio que tenemos a la izquierda
para que después tengamos dos binomios
que estén igualados a cero y ya con esto
resolver esta ecuación va a ser muy
sencillo pero ya verán a qué me refiero
con esto entonces tengo ese cuadrada
menos 2 s menos 35 lo que quiero
explicarme en dos números tales que
sumados me den menos 2 y que
multiplicados me den 35 es decir dos
números ahí ve que sumados median menos
2 y a la par su producto me tienen que
dar menos 35 y lo primero que me doy
cuenta es que si su producto tiene que
ser menos 35 tienen que ser de signos
contrarios
5 se puede descomponer en 35 y 1 en 5 y
7 5 y 7 funciona fíjate 57 me da de
resultado menos 2 y 5 por menos 7 me da
de resultado menos 35 por lo tanto ya
aquí tengo dos números que sumados me
dan menos 2 y multiplicados me dan menos
35 entonces a continuación voy a
escribir menos 2s de la siguiente manera
voy a poner ese cuadrada más 5 s menos 7
s 5 s menos 7 s es menos 2 s menos 35 es
igual a 0 y después lo que voy a hacer
es agarrar los dos primeros términos y
de aquí voy a factorizar lo más que se
pueda que si te das cuenta es ese
entonces voy a factorizar a ese que
multiplica a ese más 5 no quedaría ese
cuadrada más 5 es perfecto y después voy
a agarrar los siguientes dos términos y
de aquí también voy a factorizar lo más
que se pueda y si te das cuenta lo más
en común que tienen estos dos es el
menos 7 menos 7 que multiplicarse y
menos 7 que multiplica a más
- 7 x 5 me da menos 35 y esto tiene que
ser igual a 0 hasta aquí espero que
vayamos bien y todo en orden a este tipo
de factorización se le conoce en
factorización por agrupación porque
después nos damos cuenta de que otra vez
tenemos un factor común el factor común
en esta ocasión es ese 5 s más 5 que
multiplica quién bueno por una parte
multiplica a ese este de verde es ese y
por otra parte multiplica al menos 7 si
te das cuenta tenemos ese que multiplica
a ese más 5 menos 7 que multiplica
también a ese 5 por lo tanto me queda
ese más 5 que multiplica a ese menos 7 y
esto es igual a cero y aquí ya tenemos
dos binomios que multiplicados me dan
igual a cero y a ver vamos a pensar
tantito
si tengo dos números que multiplicados
me den cero que tiene que pasar con esos
números pues tenemos solamente de tres
opciones a veces que me escribirlo aquí
tengo dos números voy a suponer hay de
números cualesquiera que multiplicados
me dan cero
bueno pues tengo tres opciones o acero o
b es cero o ambos son cero no me queda
de otra
el primero es cero pues fíjate que cero
por lo que sea
el segundo es cero porque me va a quedar
a por cero que es cero o ambos son cero
cero por cero cero y esto es muy
importante porque quiere decir que el
primer binomio es igual a cero o en su
dado caso el segundo binomio es igual a
cero o ese más 5 es igual a cero o ese
menos 7 es igual a cero y ya tengo
ecuación es muy sencilla de resolver en
el primero el único que tengo que hacer
es restar 5 de ambos lados de la
ecuación y en el segundo sumar 7 de
ambos lados de la ecuación a ver vamos a
ver qué me queda aquí voy a quitarle 5
veamos la ecuación por lo tanto menos 5
y aquí menos 5 lo que haga de un lado lo
tengo que hacer del otro y me queda ese
5 menos 5 me queda simple y
sencillamente ese y cero menos 5 me
queda menos 5 ya que obtengo que ese es
igual a menos 5 bien ya tenemos una
primera s que es un resultado o en su
dado caso lo que voy a hacer la
siguiente ecuación es sumarle 7 de ambos
lados de la ecuación s menos 77 me queda
ese 0 más 7 me queda 7 y ya tengo mis
dos raíces de esta ecuación ya resolví
para s esta ecuación cuadrática con la
que empecé s igual a menos 5 o s
7 resultado 0 fíjate bien menos 5 al
cuadrados 25 5 por 12 10
me quedaría 35 35 me da 0 y después 7 al
cuadrados 49 14 menos 35 también a 0
perfecto ya tengo mis dos raíces pero lo
que quiero que veas es que no siempre
hay que hacer todo este procedimiento
hay veces que es mucho más fácil
resolver este tipo de ecuaciones sin
hacer esta factorización por agrupación
fíjate bien si tenemos dos binomios
multiplicados de la siguiente forma que
me va a quedar x más a por x más b me
queda x cuadrada más bx después a por x
esa equis y después a por b es b por a o
por b y bueno esto es lo mismo que x
cuadrada más ve más a ojo aquí voy a
sacar como factor como una equis y
entonces me quedaría a más b por x más a
b y esta multiplicación de binomios es
muy útil porque si te das cuenta
aquí tenemos lo mismo solamente que para
ese entonces podríamos actualizarlo de
una manera mucho más sencilla me tendría
que fijar en dos números que sumados
media menos dos a más vez tiene que ser
menos dos y dos números que multiplica
de 35 a por bs buena menos 35 y si te
das cuenta es justo lo que tenemos acá
arriba encontramos dos números que
números 5 y menos 7 por lo tanto si yo
me regreso una regresión me regreso
entonces podremos escribir esta ecuación
de la siguiente manera y bueno recuerden
que la ecuación original está escrita en
términos de s por lo tanto voy a
escribir estos binomios en términos de s
solamente que hice la analogía para el
caso de x entonces que me quedaría me
quedaría s más el primer número es más
el primer número que es 5 y después ese
más el segundo número pero como el
segundo número es negativo entonces me
va a quedar ese menos 7 es más 5 que
multiplica a ese menos 7 y esto es igual
a 0 y date cuenta que es justo lo mismo
a lo que habíamos llegado aquí abajo sin
embargo este procedimiento es un poco
más rápido que factorizar por agrupación